hello everyone I'm Alicia Malone Davis
and I'm excited Eric I'm excited too
because I'm about to see the trailer for
fantastic beasts and where to find them
now you've already cheated you've seen
this I have this is the final trip
fantastic piece we're fine an exciting
movie this is like the most anticipated
fall movie of the season Harry Potter
prequel yeah I am so excited I'm a bit
of a pothead pot ahead I don't know what
the correct terminology is but I love
Harry Potter I love all the books I love
all the movies and I can't wait to see
this movie and just get get involved in
that world again it's such a great
universe cinematic universe I guess you
could start to say this now it's as a
spinoff
it's definitely yeah that's you're
you're like the opposite of me I am NOT
I I'm familiar with Harry Potter I've
seen some of the movies I haven't read
any of the books so I'm come on Fred I
haven't read any of the books but I'm
going and you're a father I am ashamed
I'm going in so I want to go in fresh
too fantastic piece like I I I love the
cast I loved in New York setting and I'm
like alright what if I started with this
movie mm-hmm as my sort of intro into
this world and then maybe backtrack so
that's kind of what that's how I'm
approaching it that's an interesting
perspective on it and I've purposely
stayed away from the internet this
morning I you know tweeted it out then
we're going to be doing this but I
didn't look at any tweets about this
trailer I haven't watched this trailer
because I wanted to see it live and one
thing that I'm really hoping with this
trailer something that we haven't seen
yet are the beasts themselves are they
fantastic and where do you find them
that's what I want to know so I think
what we could do is get Jimmy to put the
trailer up and we'll watch it and react
to it and then talk about it afterwards
alright and it let's roll it's exciting
so far oh there you go
you know for 24 hours that an
unregistered wizard set magical beasts
loose in New York yes where is this man
[Music]
Hey so you're the guy with the case full
of monsters huh
Hughes Chavez first the suspenders do
you know anything about the Wizarding
community in America hey my feast hey
mister English guy I think your egg is
hatching the nomads what no they're not
on wizard sorry we call the muggles
I don't think I'm dreaming I'll pave it
away ain't got the brains to make this
up raping destruction and then
disappearing without a trace witches
live among us weave loose in the shadows
for too long a school who does this
potato
yes
then jet
he says Dania
this is related to Grindelwald attacks
in Europe this could mean war
we got a plan right guys that need our
help
what's that everything that came out of
the case
but let another one done I refuse to bow
down any harm
time is running out let's just commander
oh I'm so excited
ah so a couple of things firstly we've
got to say some beasts which looks
really cute we don't know the names for
them yet but that I loved seeing that
the cute little guy little Hedgehog kind
of looks almost like a platypus the same
time some of those are I think part of
the Potter universe I think that the
tree guy who I forget but it's like the
group esque yeah has a name and has been
in my part of video games I believe yeah
is like a character in there so it's
what I like about it is that they're
bringing in sort of these little pieces
of the universe of Harry Potter that you
may have seen on like a book that Harry
had or on like a pamphlet that Harry had
and they're kind of exploring those a
little bit more which is which is fun I
think for for Potter fans to see those
connections yeah absolutely I mean
that's the thing about this whole movie
is it's based on a book which is like a
textbook about fantastic beasts and then
they've made it into a film it's great
that you know JK Rowling herself Rowling
she actually wrote this script and
that's the first time writing it and
they've got so many of the dupatta
behind the scenes people come back for
it like David Yates we were talking
about before we started rolling yeah in
this world so I think that if you're a
Harry Potter fan yeah and you're coming
into this kind of with reservations of
like can they recapture the magic of
those Harry Potter movies you know they
have all of these people that worked on
those movies coming back you know that's
a big thing that you don't always get
when they kind of revisit sort of a
world or a franchise and I think the
eighth's knows what he's doing the fact
that JK Rowling is so involved in this
movie the fish she wrote the script if
she's more involved in this movie that
she wasn't any of the Harry Potter
movies you know I think that's kind of a
cool thing and and they've already
mapped out this story
yes sequel already in the works for 2018
they know what they're bringing to the
table they know how to get you excited
the music I yeah I just it looks it
looks good as a non potter fan boy yeah
what do you think of it I want to see it
you know
what I love is two old New York that's
that's what speaks me I'm a New Yorker I
love the fact that they have New York
accents actually in this movie and it's
old New York it's 1920s New York they
they have that big scene at the end
where they're flushing something through
the subways and that describes why the
subways are so horrible - exactly
because of that bloody beast the thing
that I really like about it like you
were saying is that it has elements of
Harry Potter world so it feels familiar
but at the same time it's a completely
different story it takes place in a
different timeline it's in 1920s New
York so you have the American magical
community like that line of there in the
trailer about don't you know how the
American community works the magical
community and then the idea of instead
of muggles they're called no Maj gnome
as nomads magic basically and then they
have the auras that are like the the
police and that's a you know Colin
Farrell's character who's trying to
crack down on these beasts explai going
everywhere in New York and and causing
trouble so it's a definitely a more
grown-up Harry Potter which i think is a
smart thing to do because the fans like
may have grown up with the series and so
now this feels like it's something that
is more for people my age or I can at
least justify to myself when I get so
excited about seeing it yeah Cinematic
Universe movie for adults you know you
mentioned Kyle Pharaoh he looks like
he's the villain in this movie that's
kind of but he also has something going
on Ezra Miller yeah what is that hair I
just have to say like that haircut the
bowl haircut he's such a great actor
no magic or discouraged walking here I'm
magic in here there was this there is
some little kind of connections I think
to Dumbledore which they mentioned this
other Wizard grand grand award or
something like that is his name yeah I
didn't mention connect city in
about how he's attacking Europe and I
think in the Potter sort of mythology at
this time he was a very popular Dark
Wizard yeah and he had some run-ins with
Dumbledore and there's a long history
there and without spoiling anything and
so I think that if you are kind of a
Potter head yeah that those connections
Maties maybe him being the primary
villain of this overarching franchise
absolutely which could mean that they
would go back to Europe as well and we
could see that happen to down the line
and so I think that yeah I think I like
the way they're mixing in the pot of
Mythology here and this is I think a big
thing right now - with rogue one coming
out in December they're doing something
been off story but still part of the
universe I much prefer that to just
having a remake or a sequel it's kind of
a prequel but at the same time it takes
place in a different world as well as
being the same universe if that makes
sense I was really lucky that I got to
visit the set of this last year
fantastic beasts it was amazing because
it was actually filmed in London and
Eddie Redmayne joked about that that he
said when he got the role of mute
scallops can amanda scouts kellen scarce
Kahneman I love that name he said to his
wife like pack your bags honey we're
going to New York and then he found out
no it's actually filming in London so
they filmed at the same studios as Harry
Potter the Leavesden studios the Warner
Brothers Studios big back lot and they
built these streets of New York and I
got to walk around and they had the cars
going past they had all the extras they
had steam coming out of the grates and
the costumes are beautiful because
although they brought back many people
from the Harry Potter world like there's
the guy that makes the ones is back and
I got to touch your wand I was real good
and then don't don't think too much
about that but Colleen Atwood is in
charge of all the costumes multi
oscar-winning I think which is won three
Oscars and been nominated for so many
more for her costume designs and it just
looks beautiful or the 20s style and I
was lucky that she dressed me you dress
1920s and she dressed me herself calling
that word herself took a look at me
she'd seen some photos before the shoot
and then she decided that I was gonna be
an ORAC she said that I'm a bit of a
badass she can tell so I'm like I'm not
at all but I'm glad I appear that way so
I got to dress up in some of those
outfits and walk around the streets and
for this movie yeah you could be like
I'll be like you know as part of that
yeah but it was so cool to go to the set
and to see everything I imagined for the
actors it must be so helpful to walk on
a set and have tangible like tactile
things they can touch green screen as
well of course we saw some of the
effects in the trailer like the one you
were like oh that's so cool when you go
into the briefcase yeah I was really
cool but it does seem like of course
it's gonna be so much CGI but at least
the sets were very look like they're
very realistic yeah that kind of
practicals which I think we're seeing a
lot more of now especially with the
re-emergence of like a Star Wars The
Force awakens where they're going back
to practical effects it's like we went
through the 80s which was all about
practical effects into the computer age
which was all computer-generated and now
we're sort of cycling back to that
old-school you know nice mixture you
want kind of creatures that people feel
like they can reach out and touch yeah
and and it's of course it's hard to do
when you've got something like the
fantastic beasts ah something that took
over complete creation and I imagine for
the actors to have to have to see a
flying thing and imagine it in their
heads must be tricky we've got Jean over
there on our fact-check and she said yes
Colleen has won three Oscars which is
amazing and I wouldn't be surprised if
she is nominated again for this movie
awesome it looks amazing and the
costumes are great the actors are
wonderful as well it's such an
interesting collection of actors you
were saying before we started about
Catherine Waterston yeah who's great
who's great I love her in inherent vice
paul thomas anderson movie i fell in
love with her in that film and she's Sam
Waterston's door yeah
Waterston family and cheese i think a
terrific actress when I saw her
inheriting her advice I was like she's
going to be the next big thing and I
think we're starting to see that see her
emerge now this is I think really her
first major major kind of blockbuster
movie and she's an integral part of the
film and I think it's cool to see her
kind of you know spread her wings a
little bit as an actress yeah yes she
was saying that was her first big sets
first big CG that she had to imagine and
and be involved with that well but she
loved it also you've got we mention
Colin Farrell but you've got Jon Voight
which I didn't I didn't realize that he
was in the film at all so excited to see
what role he's playing and then some
great actresses like Alison sudol who
plays the sister to Katharine
Waterston's character and she's someone
that no one would recognize the name of
and she's a newcomer but she has such a
beautiful quality about her when I was
watching them film on set that just
seems very very vulnerable at the same
time they're both strong female
characters which of course I love and
then Eddy himself ausco Anna yeah yeah
he just kind of melts he has that sort
of perfect sensibility to play this guy
who seems like he's smart and brainian
knows a lot about this specific
situation but he also seems like he's
you know little fracture yes he's a fish
out of water particularly in this world
and you can see in the trailer he's kind
of a bit hunched over a bit looking down
a little bit shy maybe and obviously
doesn't mean to cause as much trouble as
he does with his magical briefcase but
Colleen Atwood was telling me on the set
that she purposely made his vest just a
little bit too tight so he does give him
that like hunched over eighty does look
out of place and he does look like he
just doesn't quite fit anywhere so he
doesn't fit in this New York world and
he doesn't fit into his costume and I
love that Jane is reminding us that zoe
kravitz is going to be in this as well
and she
is a wonderful actress we've seen her
and she was great in dope I remember
last year Oh Mad Max fury road she was
cool she just pops up kind of and she's
really good and Dan Fogler too and she's
going to be in the sequel as well and
one thing that does look different
already but this trailer is that you
have diversity it's not all the same
looking characters as that's what a lot
of Harry Potter
you know critics of the movies were
saying that there was just a bit too
much of the same type of person that was
cast in that so I love that they're
trying different things with this movie
and hopefully it doesn't because we know
sequel is coming I'm just hoping that it
tells a complete story within itself
I think the Harry Potter films were
pretty good at doing that but they all
felt complete at the same time they all
work together yeah you don't want to
feel like your apartment getting part of
a story that should have ended yeah you
want to feel like you gotta have a
complete experience of this film and
looking forward to what the next chapter
JK Rowling like you know like we said
she wrote this she's she's masterminding
this whole thing and say can we trust or
yes we trust yeah I think it looks cool
I think if as somebody who's not you
know as obsessed with Harry Potter like
I I want to see it I think it looks cool
I think it looks like a fun fantastical
movie that speaks to sort of where we
are right now and how we want these
franchises to kind of continue to live
on yeah and see these different stories
but still kind of hang out in that
universe and I think that does
everything yes exactly I think it ticks
all the boxes for what franchises should
do and what we haven't seen much of this
summer unfortunately is something that
feels wholly original the same time it's
part of a whole series you got JK she's
writing this one she's also writing the
sequel so it will have that Harry Potter
universe explained properly Harry Potter
fans will love at the same time it'll
give you something new and I think if
you're not a Harry Potter fan hopefully
you will enjoy it just as much so let us
know in the comments below what do you
think of the final trailer for fantastic
beasts and where to find them are you as
excited as me can you not wait
November oh god I'm so excited anyway
I'm at least Mullane I am Eric Davis and
we will see you soon